bonsoir à tous vous êtes sur LCP soyez
les bienvenus dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir faut-il plafonner les prix du gaz
les 27 se réunissent à Bruxelles pour
s'accorder sur une réponse commune à la
crise énergétique car plus la guerre en
Ukraine dure et plus il devient urgent
de parvenir à baisser les prix de
l'énergie pour les citoyens et aussi
pour les entreprises mais en a-t-on
vraiment les moyens le marché de
l'énergie est-il régulable grand débat
dans un instant avec nos invités sur ce
plateau notre grand témoin ce soir est
un grand historien professeur au Collège
de France érudit passionné grand
pédagogue aussi il revisite dans son
dernier livre les grandes dates de
l'histoire mondiale
1789 1945 le tout à travers le prisme de
la mémoire Patrick Boucheron sera avec
nous dans la deuxième partie en fin deux
affranchies ce soir le philosophe
Pierre-Henri tavoyau va nous parler du
succès phénoménal d'un livre en Italie
sur Mussolini et puis Garou nous dira
Marco poli pourquoi certains élus
donnent de la voix pour freiner les
ravages du loup dans les montagnes voilà
pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et si les 27 arrivés à parler d'une
seule voix pour contenir la flambée des
prix de l'énergie c'est l'un des
dossiers les plus importants à l'agenda
du Conseil européen aujourd'hui à
Bruxelles plafonner les prix du gaz en
acheter en commun bref réguler le marché
de l'énergie pour se prémunir des crises
à venir bonsoir Charles Rodwell et merci
d'être là sur ce plateau pour la
première fois députée renaissance des
Yvelines vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires économiques à
l'assemblées qui a entendu récemment le
nouveau patron d'EDF ainsi que celui de
RTE le réseau de transport de
l'électricité bonsoir David Corman ravi
de vous retrouver sur ce plateau député
européen Europe Écologie Les Verts le
gage c'est du fossile ça c'est sûr il
faudra en sortir mais on peut pas en
sortir du jour au lendemain vous nous
direz comment vous regardez les pistes
sur la table du Conseil européen enfin
bonsoir frankville Nguyen et merci
d'être là vous êtes chercheur à
l'Institut Jacques Delors sur les
politiques de l'énergie européenne on a
besoin de vos lumières de manière
pédagogique parce que c'est un sujet
très complexe n'est-ce pas Philippe
chalmain économiste à l'Université Paris
Dauphine et spécialisée sur les marchés
des matières premières merci d'être avec
nous à distance dossiers complexe la
rubrique de Stéphane blackovski nations
doute jamais aussi bien porter son nom
si j'ai bien compris l'ami Blacko pour
ouvrir le bal tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à tous si j'ai bien compris ce soir
alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam les
chaînes info sont en train de s'exciter
sur les risques de blackout le tarif du
gaz de l'électricité vont augmenter de
15%
du coup on regarde tous un peu note de
chauffage avec inquiétude le pire c'est
les entreprises puisqu'on a l'impression
qu'une vague de faillite nous menace bon
ok on est en finale de la Coupe du Monde
pas si grave ce qui nous arrive mais
quand même il y a urgence absolue et
bien à trouver une solution pour faire
baisser le prix de l'électricité c'est
ce que disait regardez Bruno Le Maire
mais il disait pas ça aujourd'hui c'est
ça il y a trois mois il faut découpler
le prix du gaz de l'électricité donc
c'est toujours pas fait dans notre cher
Union européenne le prix de
l'électricité il est indexé sur le prix
du gaz qui s'est mis à grimper en flèche
notamment avec la guerre en Ukraine donc
nous c'est sûr que nos centrales
nucléaires elles ont un peu de mal à
passer le contrôle technique mais bon
malgré tout on produit une électricité
qui est beaucoup moins cher près du gaz
donc c'est un truc où on se retrouve
complètement dès enfin pénalisé par
rapport à notre potentiel donc ce combat
de Bruno Le Maire il a pas commencé il y
a trois mois non madame Kawa il a
commencé il y a bien plus longtemps et
ça c'est sa ministre délégué qui nous le
dit Olivier Grégoire
ça fait 15 mois que le ministre Bruno Le
Maire est à l'offensive vous le savez
pour découpler le prix du gaz et de
l'électricité c'est bien plus compliqué
qu'une hareng sur les bancs du Parlement
ça demande beaucoup de temps beaucoup de
force ça tombe bien on est en train de
mener cette bataille et on la gagnera à
force de combativité sauf que pour
l'instant 15 mois après 0 résultat vous
dites pas ça contre Bruno Le Maire non
parce que non je constate mais faut
reconnaître que effectivement
aujourd'hui quand la France tape du
point sur la table manifestement ça
n'impressionne plus grand monde cela dit
pour plaider dans le sens de Bruno de la
mer faut reconnaître que au moment où il
a poussé son il a parlé d'urgence
absolue c'était au mois d'août regarder
le prix du gaz au mois d'août on était
vraiment à des sommets bon on va dire
déliant stratosphérique musée la presse
donc ça c'est un peu calmé depuis donc
l'urgence elle est quand même moins
absolu alors peut-être que c'est parce
que Bruno Le Maire a tapé du point sur
la table tu as t-il pour le refaire
alors si ça marche c'est mauvais esprit
Myriam c'est moi normalement mais soyez
indulgent vous savez que l'Europe c'est
quand même une copropriété avec 27
propriétaires comment peut-on tomber
d'accord chacun veille son intérêt et le
pire c'est qu'on est tenté de montrer
son voisin du doigt moi par exemple je
serai tenté de montrer les Allemands du
doigt parce que les Allemands bon c'est
quand même hyper dépendant au gaz russe
maintenant que le gazoluc Nord Stream 2
a eu un petit pépin explosé c'est fini
tôt le gaz russe donc ils s'affole ils
achètent du gaz dans tous les sens mais
regardez regardez ils en ont acheté aux
Émirats ils en achète Qatar ils en
achète au Qatar non rigole madame en
Kawa sont en point sur le boycott de la
Coupe du Monde regardez les élèves des
affiches donc partout un contrat de 15
ans pour acheter du gaz liquide au Qatar
vous voyez chacun pense à toi son
intérêt qu'est-ce qui se passe vous êtes
eurosceptique ce soir un peu chauffer
mais c'est peut-être la Coupe du monde
là je deviens Chauvin mais c'est vrai
que c'est un peu la tentation pourquoi
rester dans cette copropriété à 27 alors
que on aurait peut-être les moyens de
s'offrir un petit pavillon individuel
on aurait de compte à rendre à personne
les Français adorent les pavillons
individuels vous le savez c'est une
passion française mais bon si on claque
la porte de l'Europe faut penser un peu
conséquences donc explication de Gabriel
Attal qui est le spécialiste des
explications on l'écoute vous avez
certains qui disent à ce moment-là
sortons du marché européen de l'énergie
comme ça on sort des règles qui
effectivement parfois peuvent paraître
absurdes mais si on fait ça qu'est-ce
qui se passe c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
plus importer d'énergie de nos voisins
européens on a bien vu tout à l'heure
dans la discussion qu'on a qu'on en
produit pas suffisamment aujourd'hui et
donc ça voudrait dire qu'on se
retrouvera avec un blackout si on
faisait ça alors voilà Myriam on en est
là l'Europe c'est ce qu'il y a de moins
pire mais faut reconnaître qu'on met du
temps pas mal de temps à se mettre
d'accord ça veut dire c'est pas comme si
on avait rien fait
Ursula Anders depuis le mois de
septembre dit qu'on réfléchit donc à
cette manière de réformer le marché de
l'électricité en attendant toujours pas
de plafond toujours pas de découplage
gaz électricité donc il y a vraiment
matière à un débat mais là je vous
laisse et vous les experts merci
beaucoup pour ce billet Stéphane complet
et enlever comme chaque soir je vais
commencer avec vous Philippe chalmain ou
là attention à ça à vous Stéphane en
quittant le studio Philippe almain on
connaît votre obédience libérale réguler
le marché de l'énergie pour vous c'est
quoi une hérésie je vous vois soulever
les sourcils au moins plafonné le prix
du gaz en Europe afin de se prémunir
contre les autres crises à venir est-ce
que ce serait une bonne idée
à partir du moment où nous importons
pratiquement tout notre gaz de
l'extérieur de l'Union européenne je ne
vois absolument pas comment il est
possible de plafonner le prix du gaz que
nous importons ça ça fait partie des
absurdités on peut essayer effectivement
de lisser le prix de nos importations de
gaz on nous engageant sur des contrats
de très long terme la Chine vient de
signer un accord avec le Qatar sur un
contrat de 27 ans le problème c'est
qu'il y a un certain nombre de nos
partenaires européens et même un certain
nombre de Français aussi côté vert et
autres qui disent nous devons sortir du
gaz donc on a besoin du gaz maintenant
on en aura pas besoin demain donc on
veut pas s'engager il est clair que des
pays comme le Qatar comme les Émirats
comme l'Australie ont besoin de contrats
de long terme de manière être capable
d'investir sur le long terme donc ça
c'est une première dose de plafonner
comme vous le dites à moins de s'engager
sur trop d'années après tout il faut
quand même en sortir c'est c'est du
fossile le gaz est-ce que acheter en
commun ce serait une solution
intelligente d'un point de vue
économique et pour les citoyens aussi
acheter en commun si on est prêt à
s'engager sur le très long terme oui
quand on achète sur le marché spot que
vous achetiez tout seul ou en groupe
c'est à peu près pareil maintenant
l'autre chose il y a le prix du gaz il y
a la liaison entre le prix du gaz et de
l'électricité et là il y a quand même
une perspective Bruno Le Maire a
totalement raison vous avez dit que
j'étais un économiste libéral mais le
libéralisme s'arrête quand même à
certaines limites est-ce que on peut
considérer l'électricité sur lequel
finalement nous avons largement
contribué en termes d'investissement
public est-ce que l'électricité
peut-être considérée comme une matière
première communauté je n'en suis pas sûr
et donc on pourrait tout à fait imaginer
revenir comme nous l'avions autrefois à
un système de prix administré de
l'électricité maintenant très
franchement quand on regarde les
positions d'un certain nombre de
partenaires européens nos chers
Allemands les Néerlandais etc je ne
pense pas qu'on y parviendra donc
malheureusement pardonnez-moi de vous
interrompre à distance c'est difficile
de dialoguer pour terminer les Allemands
disent si vous plafonnez le prix du gaz
demain les pays qui ont du gaz iront
voir d'autres consommateurs d'autres
acheteurs et ne nous donneront plus de
gaz on pourra pas sécuriser nos
approvisionnements vous vous croyez que
c'est vrai
attendez les Allemands et un petit peu
parce que Olaf Scholtz est allé se
balader dans le golfe il n'y a pas très
très longtemps tout content il revient
avec honte contrat avec les Émirats et
c'était un contrat non pas sur 27 ans
comme les Chinois c'était un contrat sur
15 ans et immédiatement il y a eu une
réaction du ministre de l'Environnement
allemand qui a dit si jamais
nous ne pouvions pas tenir ce contrat ce
contrat a été signé par des parties
privées ce qui est exact et donc on
pourrait éventuellement revendre le gaz
dont nous n'aurions plus besoin sur le
marché international je crois qu'il faut
arrêter cette sorte de diktates que l'on
entend beaucoup trop souvent aujourd'hui
qui est de dire qu'on peut se passer du
gaz alors je voudrais simplement si vous
m'en donnez le temps vous dire ce qui
vient de se passer sur le marché
britannique il y a seulement trois jours
et il y a trois jours
il y a eu une vague de froid au
Royaume-Uni encore pire
que il y a beaucoup de
froid au Royaume-Uni l'électricité à 28%
en temps normal elle vient de l'énergie
éolienne dimanche et lundi on était
tombé à 3 %. qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
énorme demande d'électricité bah
justement à partir de gaz sachant que le
Royaume-Uni est un peu isolé donc les
câbles sous-marins ne suffisait pas le
prix de l'électricité a totalement
flambé nous sommes actuellement des
fossiles du jour au lendemain c'est une
évidence on comprend ce que vous voulez
et il faut se dire que l'éolien le
solaire c'est très bien il faut que nous
puissions sur la biomasse c'est pas mal
d'autres choses mais il faut accepter
aussi le fait que le gaz nous en aurons
probablement besoin pour les 20 ou 30
années à venir ou 30 années à venir
merci professeur chalmain j'ai envie de
dire Merci à VOUS David Corman elle est
pour vous cette question forcément
écologistes on aura besoin du gaz il
faut se le dire au moins dans les vins à
30 années à venir
je pense que si on avait anticipé comme
les écologistes le disent depuis 30 ou
40 ans on en aurait à mini moi moins
besoin aujourd'hui on a fait une étude
on a on a commandé une étude au niveau
du Parlement européen qui nous dit qu'on
peut en 2040 donc c'est pas dans 30 ans
dans 18 ans être à 100% d'énergie
renouvelable pas que pour l'électricité
pour tout en Union européenne avec avec
de la sobriété au passage important
c'est-à-dire économie d'énergie
drastiquement changement de vie de
logiciel
regardez pourquoi va pas y avoir de
blackout cet hiver la vraie raison là
tout de suite maintenant c'est parce que
la consommation a baissé de quasiment
10%. alors on va y venir vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir eu votre vie
quotidienne complètement
massacré depuis un mois non mais je
pense qu'il faut pas répéter cette idée
que il y aura une fatalité à continuer
dans le mode de vie énergétique dans
lequel nous sommes et donc il faut pas
évacuer la question de la sobriété comme
étant un truc de Fada c'est quelque
chose vous en tant que écologiste qu'on
ne peut pas
au lendemain sortir du fossile c'est
plus que les écologistes il y a pas que
les écologistes qui disent le GIEC dit
ça tout le monde dit ça il y a pas de
non mais on peut pas continuer à habiter
la terre la transition oui mais
maintenant il faut commencer à le faire
là ce qu'on nous entend et à chaque fois
c'est la même histoire c'est de dire ça
peut pas être avant 20 ou 30 ans déjà
c'est faux on peut le faire avant 20 ans
alors on a commencé méta on va
redescendre un tout petit peu parce
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de sujets déjà
dans la conversation avec avec le
professeur shelma Charles vous doit
d'abord j'entends juste ce que David
comment disait l'instant j'ai une petite
astérisque qui a apporté certes notre
consommation d'électricité et d'énergie
ABC de 10% sur le mois passé et c'est un
accomplissement majeur et les premières
avoir fait l'effort et c'est tout à fait
normal c'est l'état et ce sont les
grandes entreprises en France
la deuxième des choses et je pense qu'il
faut quand même qu'on salue ce qu'ils
ont fait depuis des semaines désormais
ce sont les salariés de DF ingénieurs et
ouvriers d'EDF qui ont remis en route un
certain nombre de centrales nucléaires
et de réacteurs nucléaire
de relancer la production d'électricité
par le nucléaire en France on revient
sur l'Europe et on va revenir après sur
la France vraiment
au moins je parle de la sobriété pour
éviter de production pour éviter les
coupures pour éviter les coupures
c'est symptomatique mais parce que vous
prenez les problèmes à l'enversé
était supérieure à la production vous me
parlez de la consommation qui baisse
c'est vrai ce qui nous permet mais la
raison pour laquelle nous n'aurons pas
de coupure cet hiver vraisemblablement
c'est aussi parce que la production a
augmenté et la production augmenter
parce que nous avons remis en route nos
réacteurs nucléaires
sur 55 qui fonctionnent en France absent
mieux mais enfin c'est la moindre des
choses de répondre il y a des efforts
qui ont été faits d'accord il faut juste
rappeler aussi qu'il y a des réacteurs
qui ont été remis en route pour normal
que des réacteurs complétés
il fonctionne toujours pas celui-ci ce
qui est sûr c'est que les filles ont
nucléaire est allé dans le mur depuis
l'accord mortifère que vous avez passé
en 2012 avec François Hollande vous
pensez que le père de l'accord mais vous
répétez cette facture vous prenez à
votre compte c'est parce que j'ai dit
j'ai simplement dit que la filière
nucléaire en France ça n'a rien été mis
en difficulté depuis des années
notamment depuis l'accord électorale
vous avez vous aurez l'occasion
sur le nucléaire c'est normal mais moi
je voudrais qu'on revienne au Conseil
européen un instant parce qu'il y a des
décisions importantes on parlera de la
France et des risques de blackout ou pas
vous vous êtes l'expert sur le sujet
restons sur l'Europe à l'instant
plafonner le prix du gaz on voit qu'il y
a vraiment les camps du pour l'Espagne
notamment qui a l'impression que tout
son industrie va s'écrouler si le prix
continue à augmenter et puis les
Allemands qui ont très clairement voilà
des réticences ce projet va-t-il aboutir
selon vous oui vraisemblablement les
chefs d'État et de gouvernement ont
renvoyé la balle au ministre qui dans le
ministre de l'Énergie donc Agnès et ses
homologues qui vont se réunir la semaine
prochaine très peu de désaccords
désormais on va surtout chercher à
savoir à quel niveau de prix on va
déclencher ce fameux plafond le plafond
à quel prix s'il est très élevé ça sert
à rien désormais l'objectif est de dire
qu'à partir à un certain prix on
arrêtera d'acheter du gaz pourquoi parce
que ça résultera de manipulation de
marché qui sont vraisemblablement dû à
Vladimir Poutine qui prétextera des
problèmes sur des turbings qui
prétextera des problèmes
d'approvisionnement pour tenter de faire
monter artificiellement les prix il fera
des effets pour les citoyens peut-être
pas pour les Français parce qu'il y a
déjà beaucoup d'aide tous les boucliers
tarifaires mais pour les Espagnols par
exemple est-ce que le prix avec ce
plafond va baisser si les mises en place
même un on entend dire 200 euros pour le
pour le prix plafond soyons honnêtes pas
forcément pourquoi parce que déjà on est
dans l'inconnu lorsqu'on met en place le
plafond de prix ça n'a jamais été fait
auparavant et donc on anticipe des
réactions de marché mais aucune
certitude là-dessus ensuite il faut le
dire une chose c'est que un plafond de
prix n'incite pas à la réduction de la
demande et donc là on revient à la
logique de sobriété énergétique à partir
du moment où vous plafonnez les prix les
gens ont tendance à consommer de la même
manière puisque le prix justement est
bloqué l'objectif est de dire qu'il faut
d'abord tenter de rendre obligatoire les
objectifs de une réduction de la demande
pour faire en sorte que d'une part on
baisse notre consommation très
intelligent de plafonner on a quand même
vécu 100% d'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité sur un an il faut être
capable d'y faire face si ça se
reproduit la fenêtre ça peut avoir un
avantage c'est de dire à Vladimir
Poutine nous sommes prêts à rentrer dans
ce rapport de force que vous nous mettez
en place par contre il faut aussi dire
une chose très concrètement plafonner
les prix ne résoudra pas les problèmes
que l'on voit à l'heure actuelle sur la
formation des prix sur le marché de
l'électricité pourquoi parce qu'en fait
le gaz à l'heure actuelle est
indispensable pour assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement électrique au sein
de l'Union européenne et sans gaz à
l'heure actuelle on n'aurait pas
d'électricité pour pour s'éclairer ou
pour se chauffer alors je vais vous dire
très concrètement cette question de la
réforme du marché de l'électricité de la
tarification de l'électricité chez
drudoile déjà pour bien comprendre qui a
pris cette décision d'où vient
l'indexation du prix de l'électricité
sur celui du gaz alors il y a deux
éléments dans ce que vous avez posé
actuellement c'est un l'achat du gaz et
de deux l'indexation du prix de
l'électricité sur le prix du gaz il y a
un sujet que vous avez souligné qui est
extrêmement important tout à l'heure
avec Monsieur chalmain c'est que le
plafonnement vient avec l'achat en
commun aujourd'hui il y a pas d'intérêt
à plafonner le prix du gaz si on dit pas
ensemble que nous payons par exemple
voilà nous payons on va acheter en
commun notre gaz payer par pays mais sur
des critères communs et dans dans une
dynamique commune parce que aux yeux de
nos producteurs mondiaux c'est pas la
même chose
67 ou de 82 millions d'habitants et un
marché démographique économique
politique industrielle de 450 à 500
millions d'habitants c'est la première
des choses ensuite la deuxième des
choses la fameuse décorrélation entre
les prix de l'électricité et le prix du
Gaza c'est le combat de Bruno Le Maire
celui d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'on a
une chance d'y parvenir moi je pense
qu'on a une chance d'y parvenir pourquoi
parce qu'on sent que dans cette période
les lignes bougent
quand on entend Philippe Chalain qui est
un ponte dans son domaine prendre sa
position qu'il a prise sur la
réglementation des prix de l'électricité
on sent que les lignes rouges et
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle bouge parce que
je crois que les lignes en Europe
bougent quand on parle de principe
simple à la sortie de la crise covid on
est parti d'un principe commun où les
États européens se sont dit il faut
qu'on se relance ensemble il faut qu'on
relance nos industries nous entreprises
notre consommation et qu'on protège nos
citoyens de la crise covid ensemble en
partant de ce principe là on a trouvé
des accords pour le coup assez
historiques pour relancer nos économies
en commun moi je suis absolument
persuadé sur l'énergie qu'on est dans
une situation similaire aujourd'hui
expliquez-nous pourquoi nous qui avons
l'avantage comparatif d'avoir du
nucléaire bon marché grâce aux central
merci général de Gaulle ou pas David
Corman vous nous direz mais est-ce que
est-ce que Kika qui a fait que on a
accepté d'où vient cette règle d'indexer
l'électricité sur le gaz parce que
EDF vend aux Français plus cher puisque
plus le prix du gaz monte plus
d'électricité monte alors tout dépend
déjà du tarif auquel vous vous
concrètement lorsque vous allez voir EDF
ou deux fournisseurs quels sont les
tarifs auxquels vous souscrivez et quels
sont les contrats auxquels vous
souscrivez en fait le marché européen
par d'un principe simple c'est que les
pays européens entre eux sont capables
d'importer et d'exporter du gaz ou du
l'électricité entre eux mais non pas par
jour par semaine mais même au sein d'une
heure heure par heure il y a des moments
de la journée où la France dans une
période normale importe de l'électricité
de l'Europe de l'Est il y a d'autres
moments de la journée où elle export de
l'électricité va l'Europe de la c'est
notamment le travail que fait une
entreprise en France qui s'appelle RTE
qui l'entreprise de transport de
l'électricité et ce marché a fonctionné
pendant des années il a une vertu forte
que soulignée Gabriel Attal dans son
dans son intervention c'est de nous
permettre justement d'équilibrer ses
approvisionnements entre pays européens
mais aujourd'hui il a un défaut majeur
la France depuis des décennies investis
dans son énergie renouvelable et dans
son énergie nucléaire et donc elle bâtit
d'une énergie qui est l'énergie du gaz
qui est une énergie fossile sur laquelle
d'autres pays ont investi et qui nous
pénalisent collectivement aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous êtes favorable David
Corman à changer les règles de fixation
des prix de l'électricité en Europe
la question quand même qu'il faut poser
sur l'histoire de de pas avoir un prix
qui est le réel prix c'était aussi une
logique libérale et vous avez bien fait
de rappeler que notre ami économiste
était de cette inspiration là et ça
c'est des choix stratégiques économiques
qui sont contestables et effectivement
c'est devrait être une évidence mais la
question est pas que l'électricité de
l'énergie aussi quand elle exporte avec
une énergie électrique EDF de mon point
de vue on a mal profité d'abord vous
dites comme une vérité établie que la
France bénéficie d'une électricité bon
marché grâce au nu pardonnez-moi de vous
dire que je le conteste je le conteste
aujourd'hui est une EDF est une
entreprise qui est endettée à hauteur de
45 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui Areva
qui était l'entreprise les EPM
vous avez la filière du démantèlement
qui est sous-évaluée et compris la
remise en état des centrales dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure on appelle ça le
grand carénage a été sous-évalué écoute
très cher donc voilà je veux bien qu'on
dise tout ce qu'on veut mais si la
France qui est le pays du monde qui a le
plus misé sur le nucléaire avait trouvé
une sorte de martingale qui nous
permettait d'être une surpuissance
énergétique franchement le saurait ça
fait 40 ans qu'on met nos yeux dans le
même panier pour répondre à votre
question quand même y compris sur la
question nucléaire vous dites on exporte
on importe selon les moments du jour de
l'énergie c'est vrai sauf que depuis
plusieurs mois notre solde et créditeur
ça compte n'importe plus y compris
l'Allemagne de l'électricité d'origine
nucléaire et j'entends parfois derrière
il y a un accord qui a été fait entre
Macron et Monsieur Scholtz il y a
quelques semaines qui dit quoi on
s'engage de livrer du gaz pas de
l'électricité nucléaire du gaz à
l'Allemagne en échange de quoi
d'électricité y compris nucléaire
allemand européenne ça s'appelle que le
mythe selon lequel les méchants
allemands avec leur gros gaz et nous les
génies avec le nucléaire on donne des
leçons la terre entière ce n'est pas la
réalité c'est tout ce que je dis et donc
si on veut avoir si on veut avoir une
vision
soutenable de l'avenir il y a pardon oui
la question de la sobriété qui est
fondamentale et deuxièmement quand on
dit qu'on a beaucoup investi dans le
nucléaire et le renouvelable comme vous
l'avez dit surtout dans le nucléaire et
d'ailleurs la France et le seul pays des
27 qui est en retard sur renouvelable
alors on vient d'être condamné une
amende de 500 millions d'euros par
l'Union européenne parce que nous
n'avons pas assez investi c'est pas à
faute c'est pas à cause du gouvernement
que vous soutenez c'est quelque chose
qui vient beaucoup plus
la situation c'est qu'il fallait
redonner de la visibilité à ces deux
filières c'est ce que nous avons fait
lors du premier quinquennat et c'est ce
que nous entreprenons aujourd'hui avec
l'investissement à la fois dans six
réacteurs nucléaires et en même temps
dans le développement et c'est la loi
qu'on est en train d'étudier aujourd'hui
donc
il y aura une loi sur le nucléaire
il vous écoute mais il aimerait aussi
participer à ce débat trois anciens
patrons de DF ont été auditionnés à
l'Assemblée nationale dans le cadre de
la commission d'enquête sur le nucléaire
justement Henri Broglio Jean-Bernard
Lévy et puis pierre ganoë gadoneix ont
tous eu des mots très durs pour dénoncer
le mécanisme de l'arène on y revient et
vous nous expliquer ça juste après
la reine est une monstruosité qu'est-ce
qui justifie que DF subventionne ses
concurrents
alors je fais l'avocat de adverse la
justification c'est de dire que DF a de
fait un monopole en ayant le coup du
nucléaire et que personne ne peut en
bénéficier et donc personne ne pourra
jamais investir dans ce domaine donc la
seule manière pour que les autres
puissent investir c'est qu'ils aient une
partie de la rente nucléaire voilà la
justification regardez aucun de ceux qui
ont bénéficié de la rente d'investi ni
dans le nucléaire ni dans même dans la
production voilà les procès sont très
lourds en fait déjà sur le nucléaire
tous les anciens patrons disent la même
chose on n'aurait pas dû accepter ces
règles du jeu expliquez-nous ce que
c'est que la reine alors déjà la reine
c'est un acronyme ça veut dire accès
régulier à l'électricité nucléaire
historique c'était en partant du
principe que EDF est en situation de
monopole et donc les concurrents qui
voulaient entrer sur le marché étaient
évidemment défavorisées l'objectif était
donc de dire eDF va vendre à une partie
de ses concurrents qui fournissent de
l'électricité donc une partie de sa
production d'une certaine manière une
partie de sa production leur a été
vendue et ensuite ces fournisseurs
d'électricité pouvaient proposer des
offres avantageuses aux clients pour
pouvoir tenter de les séduire et que
c'est que que nous vous et moi nous
puissions aller chez ces fournisseurs
dans le nucléaire alors c'est vrai qu'il
faut regarder ce qu'on en fait les
fournisseurs d'électricité force et de
constater que ces fournisseurs
d'électricité n'ont pas investi dans des
capacités de production d'électricité et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on est en
difficulté alors aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle on est dans une situation où
nous n'avons pas assez ni de nucléaire
ni d'énergie renouvelable pour répondre
à nos besoins d'électricité et donc là
ça pose un problème sur le fait aussi à
cause de ses règles là par exemple qu'on
n'a pas tout nos réacteurs au niveau
alors non les réacteurs au niveau c'est
dû au fait qu'il y a eu un
sous-investissement sur ces questions là
vis-à-vis de la filière et en même temps
le principal problème c'est que
l'énergie la production d'électricité la
plus rapidement déployable ce sont les
énergies renouvelables et nous n'avons
pas assez investi sur ces énergies
renouvelables au cours des 10 15
dernières années si on regarde si on
regarde sur nos voisins européens la
France est le seul pays vous l'avez
rappelé à ne pas voir attends ces
objectifs mais c'est pas seulement la
production d'électricité renouvelable
c'est également sur la chaleur
renouvelable donc c'est la géothermie
c'est également les pompes à chaleur et
ça en même temps sur le transport nous
sommes vraiment en retard et donc le
projet de loi accélération énergie
renouvelable ne permettra pas de
répondre à son retard il faut encore
plus accélérer et potentiellement
rehausser les annonces qui ont été
faites à Belfort si on veut être
crédible et si on veut s'engager sur une
véritable stratégie de bicarbonate donc
si je vous comprends bien
potentiellement beaucoup plus de
sobriété aussi parce que on ne pourra
pas créer du renouvelable si vite que ça
c'est donc le scénario de court terme
doit-on craindre des coupures de courant
vous y avez un peu déjà répondu lundi le
pic de consommation d'électricité a été
franchie sans difficulté de quoi à la
fois rassurer les Français mais aussi le
gouvernement qui joue gros d'ici la fin
de l'hiver elle vient mon dingava
après un petit vent de panique soufflé
par le gouvernement les nouvelles sont
plutôt rassurantes le gestionnaire du
réseau électrique RTE c'est montrer
optimiste devant les sénateurs hier ce
qu'on peut dire déjà aujourd'hui c'est
que nous avons écarté le scénario le
plus contraint celui du bas le scénario
le scénario du pire on est dans une
situation qui reste une situation de
grande vigilance et en matière de risque
je tiens quand même à dire que nous
avons certainement les moyens d'éviter
des coupures lundi un pic de
consommation a été surmonté sans
encombre tout d'abord EDF a pu
redémarrer certains de ces réacteurs le
parc nucléaire français a atteint une
capacité disponible de 41 gigawatts soit
les deux tiers de sa capacité maximum il
y a une chose c'est que plus on a de
nucléaire et plus on passe l'hiver sera
non là ce qui fait qu'on a ces tensions
sur le réseau d'électricité c'est qu'on
a peu de nucléaires donc évidemment à
chaque fois que Joseph remet en service
des réacteurs nucléaires à chaque fois
que DF augmente la disponibilité du
nucléaire on se rapproche d'un niveau de
marge qui est plus confortable pour cet
hiver les centrales à charbon à gaz
ainsi que les productions éoliennes
photosvoltaïques et hydraulique ont
aussi permis de compléter la
provisionnement en électricité malgré
cela la production française n'a pas
suffi à couvrir le pic de consommation
de lundi la France a importé de
l'électricité en provenance de ses
voisins grâce à un mécanisme
d'assistance mutuelle mais elle en a
aussi exporté enfin les effets de la
sobriété se font sentir parfois subie
quand les entreprises sont obligées de
réduire leurs production à cause des
coûts de l'énergie mais souvent
volontaire avec les efforts des Français
ainsi on a pu noter une baisse de 9,7%
de la consommation d'électricité la
semaine dernière par rapport à la
moyenne des années précédentes hors
crise sanitaire même constat pour le
phase avec moins 10,5% depuis le 1er
août pour l'instant donc le signal
Ecowatt censé prévenir de difficultés
d'approvisionnement et d'éventuels
coupures n'a jamais été activé mais cela
ne signifie pas qu'il ne pourrait pas
l'être en janvier une grande inconnue
les conditions météorologiques
[Musique]
voilà Charles rodoye jusqu'ici tout va
bien on a envie de dire mais on a quand
même dû acheter de l'électricité à nos
voisins et ça c'est quand même un peu un
échec un échec peut-être collectif du
point de vue des dirigeants mais un
échec français ça vous le reconnaissez
aujourd'hui enfin l'effort qui a été
fait le fait qu'aujourd'hui a priori le
risque de téléstage est éviter c'est un
la production mais c'est également ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure et on avait
un point d'accord c'était la baisse de
la consommation en général tant des
entreprises que des Français mais le
sujet que vous mentionniez tout à
l'heure et est tout à fait intéressant
ce ma circonscription vous avez le
centre RTE réseau de transport
d'électricité d'Île-de-France et de
Normandie en fait il faut imaginer un
arbre un arbre avec aura racine l'entrée
de l'électricité à travers les éoliennes
les panneaux phonopholtaïques les
centrales nucléaires l'importation et
ensuite le bout des branches ben en fait
le réseau enedis grosso modo les écoles
les mairies les hôpitaux les industries
l'Assemblée nationale les maisons les
appartements et en fait l'ensemble de la
consommation et à chaque minute à chaque
seconde vous avez des ingénieurs RTE qui
trouvent les équilibres en fait dans
l'arbre pour permettre à l'ensemble de
réseau de tenir lorsqu'il y a des
tensions lorsqu'il a des tensions c'est
ce qui était évoqué c'est pas toute la
journée c'est à des heures de pique
souvent le matin et ensuite le soir le
soir par exemple lorsque concrètement
des bureaux sont encore allumés et en
fonctionnement alors que certains autres
Français sont déjà rentrés chez eux dans
leur domicile c'est quand même
encourageant vous êtes d'accord David
comment 82
gowatts à 19h lundi dernier et le signal
éco web n'a pas été activé c'est un pic
de consommation important qui pourrait
d'ailleurs ne pas être dépassé pendant
le mois qui vient donc pas de délestage
en vue ça vous rassure
comme tout le monde moi plus que les
Françaises et les Français la situation
font moi qui m'interroge c'est comment
on a pu se retrouver dans cette
situation là on est la première l'Europe
la première puissance économique du
monde et le manque de prévoyance par
rapport à
comment dire le coupage des robinets par
Poutine moi mes frais un petit peu
c'est-à-dire que en vrai ce que j'ai le
sentiment c'est que on improvise avec
effectivement l'inventivité des
Françaises et des Français le travail
des salariés d'EDF etc etc mais c'est
pas très sérieux de pas avoir anticipé
les choses plutôt de responsable c'est
qui c'est EDF non parce que DF en
réalité
en France EDF et l'État c'est la même
chose donc en fait vous avez une une
abrécation entre les deux je pense qu'on
a et quand on est tout à l'heure
je sais plus
il oublie un peu les choses c'est-à-dire
qu'il dit il a raison sur la subtilité
de la reine mais la raison pour laquelle
aussi à l'époque les autres pays
européens ont dit à EDF vous êtes gentil
mais vous pouvez pas continuer à avoir
un monopole de la distribution c'est que
DF se conduisait dans d'autres pays
européens comme prédateurs économique
donc les pays voisins disaient mais vous
êtes sympa mais vous vous avez 60
millions de clients captifs en France
dans lesquels on peut pas aller c'était
ça la logique éthologique absurde c'est
pour ça qu'il faut un service public de
l'énergie je voudrais vous donner la
parole pour terminer ce débat la France
a ses intérêts elle a son parc nucléaire
qui marche plus ou moins bien et puis il
y a l'Europe est-ce que les intérêts
français en matière d'énergie et
d'électricité principalement avec le
renouvelable à venir peuvent être
défendus au mieux dans cette union oui
parce qu'au final la France s'y
retrouvera il faut rappeler qu'en temps
normal la France est exportatrice
d'électricité et donc dans ce marché
européen elle fait de l'argent pendant
de l'électricité à ses voisins à la
Belgique à l'Espagne à l'Italie etc à
l'heure actuelle on est dans une
situation pour la première fois en été
on a importé de l'électricité et en
hiver on importera encore cette
électricité on va le payer un prix très
cher donc maintenant la France doit
faire deux choses c'est d'une part très
rapidement investir dans les capacités
de production d'électricité et en même
temps réfléchir à comment elle peut être
utile à la réforme du marché européen de
l'électricité mais avec un impératif à
mon avis c'est de rappeler que malgré
tous les défauts qu'à ce marché européen
de l'électricité à l'heure actuelle en
Europe on n'a pas eu de blackout on a
réussi à maintenir et c'est le maître
mot de votre intervention tout à l'heure
l'équilibre entre le système électrique
c'est-à-dire qu'en permanence on doit
équilibrer l'offre d'électricité donc la
production d'électricité et la demande
d'électricité c'est-à-dire qu'on génère
vous et moi sans ça on est dans une
situation de la caout et à l'heure
actuelle ce sont les centrales à gaz qui
permettent cet équilibre et c'est pour
ça que le prix de l'électricité à partir
du moment où le gaz a été multiplié par
8 va suivre cette logique là et
connaître des niveaux de prix qui sont
assez démentiel merci beaucoup c'était
très clair merci pour cet effort de
pédagogie sur un sujet extrêmement
important concernant indirectement c'est
la facture des Français mais en même
temps extrêmement technique merci à vous
on va accueillir à présent notre grand
témoin c'est un grand historien je vous
le disais professeur au Collège de
France et Rudy passionné grand pédagogue
aussi dans son dernier livre au seuil il
revisite les grandes dates de l'histoire
1482 1789 comment se créer l'événement
comment l'histoire fait date à travers
le prisme de la mémoire Patrick
Boucheron rejoint juste après
l'invitation de Baptiste garguichardier
si on vous invite Patrick Boucheron
c'est pour votre dernière ouvrage
de quand l'histoire fait date un livre
adapté de votre émission sur Arte pour
défriser le cours du temps
l'idée au fond c'est de raconter une
histoire et de raconter comment on peut
la raconter
mais Patrick Boucheron qui êtes-vous un
historien du Moyen-Âge et de la
Renaissance oui mais vous aimez écrire
vous interrogez avec ce souci de
transmettre car vous êtes aussi
professeur au Collège de France votre
ouvrage le plus marquant sans doute
l'histoire mondiale de la France mais
dans votre dernier livre chaque
événement apparaît comme la porte
d'entrée d'une histoire en lien avec les
mémoires les événements les plus anciens
ne sont pas forcément les moins présents
dans notre vie ils peuvent revenir il
ressurgissent ça fait pas date d'un coup
parfois un traumatisme ça peut d'une
certaine manière retardée ses effets et
puis on s'en souvient et puis on y
revient bah c'est la même chose avec
l'histoire
ce livre un voyage long érudit qui
démarre 18000 ans avant Jésus-Christ
dans les grottes de Lascaux pour finir
en 1990 à la libération de cet homme
personne Mandela votre plume 17 le temps
passé pour nous faire comprendre les
ambiguïtés
les embûches de l'histoire
avec cette frise nous acceptons de
revenir un temps dans la salle de classe
dites-vous car vous nous prenez par la
main vous aimez raconter tout en mettant
en perspective l'événement
vous dites avoir écrit un livre ludique
sur des problèmes qui se pensent avec
des dates incertaines mais pourtant vous
confier oubliez les dates et ajouter les
dates files devant moi
insaisissables vous êtes attachés aux
événements mais alors question Patrick
Boucheron quelle importance devons-nous
leur accorder
bonsoir Patrick Boucheron et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir sur
LCP alors vous qui n'avez jamais su les
retenir ces fameuses dates quelle
importance leur accorder l'importance
qui qui s'adresse à nos vies en fait
c'est pas qu'une question de théorique
c'est pas qu'une question scolaire quand
je dis que j'oublie les dates ça peut
être malheureusement j'en sais pas très
fier les dates d'anniversaire les
grandes dates de ma vie donc ça veut
dire que au fond c'est pas si évident
que ça une chronologie elle n'a la
netteté des frises scolaires que dans
j'irai l'esprit de ceux qui pensent que
l'histoire ne s'adresse pas à nos vies
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse dans
l'histoire c'est comment elle peut nous
bouleverser comment elle peut nous
déstabiliser et puis il y a des
événements qui sont très anciens et qui
sont très présents chez nous et puis
d'autres plus récents qu'on oublie
comment vous la définiriez cette date le
mot date pour l'historien que vous êtes
vous dites dans votre livre quand
l'histoire fait date donc au seuil c'est
de la porte d'entrée d'une histoire qui
se veut accueillante aux imaginaires aux
mémoires aux émotions oui parce que j'ai
envie de faire mon métier de manière
exigeante je ne fais pas que raconter
des histoires j'essaie de raconter aussi
comment on les raconte et ça pour moi
c'est une question j'allais dire presque
politique on peut le dire sur votre
chaîne pas seulement
divertir ou intéressé mais rappelez que
l'histoire des historiennes et des
historiens n'a pas tout à fait la même
valeur que les discours sur le passé des
hommes politiques par exemple mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça on risque d'être un
peu un petit peu péremptoire ou ennuyeux
alors moi j'ai voulu prendre oui cette
porte d'entrée parce que la date c'est
ce qu'il y a de plus simple alors c'est
pas simplement 1515 Marignan mais c'est
voilà les grandes dates révolutionnaires
des journées révolutionnaires
bien au contraire puisque vous raccordez
vous racontez comment certainement
secret et vous recensez 10 manières de
créer enfin c'est une dynamique la
création d'un événement qui peut-être
s'ignore être tel quel alors il y a par
exemple les années rondes les années en
zéro l'an 1000 l'an 2000 les premiers
jours prenons cet exemple la fiction des
origines moins 753 avant notre ère la
fondation de Rome qui a fait cette date
et ben justement à cette date il faut
lui poser la question qui quitte à fait
quitte a fait date c'est-à-dire de quand
date la date alors on pourrait dire que
évidemment nous femmes et hommes du 21e
siècle on ne croit pas que Rome ne s'est
fait en un jour donc quand on dit la
fondation de Rome c'est le mythe de
fondation de Rome alors je pourrais dire
simplement c'est depuis le premier
siècle avant notre ère que les Romains
se racontent cela racontent se raconte
l'histoire des d'un commencement il lieu
d'un premier jour mais en fait lorsque
les AR un blog essaye de comprendre
comment cette ville de Rome c'est une
certaine manière développée un manque de
peau il tombe à peu près à des endroits
chronologiquement comparables au milieu
du 8e siècle c'est donc il y a quelque
chose et c'est donc entre le mythe et
l'histoire on peut réduire la mâchoire
alors je vous donne une autre date parce
que c'est passionnant de vous écouter
1492 et ce pied ce pied à nouveau
mythique de Christophe Colomb on va le
voir sur cette image racontez-nous vous
dites on a besoin de penser 1492 comme
l'entrée dans la modernité comme le
nouveau monde mais c'est plus compliqué
vous dites plus épais que ça cette année
c'est une date épaisse parce que là nous
sommes le 2 octobre 1492 mais cette
année qui est l'année du monde elle a
commencé le 2 janvier avec l'entrée des
rois catholiques dans l'Alhambra
c'est-à-dire la dernière citadelle de de
l'émirats Nasrid à Grenade et qui était
le dernier réduit de la présence
musulmane en Espagne et puis deux mois
plus tard l'expulsion des Juifs donc
c'est ici c'est la modernité elle se
paye d'un prix assez exorbitant qu'on va
appeler plus tard au 16e siècle la
l'idéal de la pureté de sang
lutter d'une certaine façon contre
l'imaginaire ou la mémoire qui a été
fabriquée autour de cette date
évidemment c'est un explorateur c'est la
découverte du nouveau monde alors
l'historien de profession il peut pas
simplement courir derrière les
imaginaires en essayant de dire c'est
plus compliqué que ça en étant le
rabat-joie de de nos émotions là et
d'une certaine manière qui produisent
aussi des imaginaires d'autres
imaginaires et là évidemment on a un
problème avec Christophe Colomb on voit
que sa statue et bien est moins
solidement Boulonnais et qu'elle ne le
fut pourquoi parce que avec lui commence
l'occidentalisation du monde le massacre
des Indiens etc c'est pas pour ça qu'il
faut le jeter à l'eau mais on va le voir
différemment nous sommes à l'Assemblée
nationale forcément je vais vous parler
de la Révolution là encore elle ne sait
pas faite en un jour et pourtant on ne
retient que la date du 14 juillet vous
lui préférez vous l'expliquez le Jeu de
Paume avec ce tableau de David
expliquez-nous pourquoi ce tableau de
David il devait être justement au-dessus
de la tribune de l'Assemblée nationale
c'était ça l'idée parce que à ce moment
là ce qui se s'invente le 20 juin 1789
avec le Serment du Jeu de Paume
c'est-à-dire le la conjuration au sens
propre un serment pris ensemble des
députés du tiers qui jurent de ne pas se
quitter
et donc c'est la naissance de la
souveraineté nationale c'est en même
temps la naissance de l'Assemblée
nationale et d'une certaine manière des
Archives nationales ils savent qu'ils
font l'histoire sans savoir laquelle
c'est ça alors c'est ça qui est très
intéressant parce que on peut dire ils
prennent date avec l'avenir c'est une
journée révolutionnaire parce que cette
journée révolutionne leur vie mais quand
j'ai été interrogé timothytaquette parce
que évidemment je ne suis pas historien
de tout ça je suis un lecteur d'abord
de l'histoire révolutionnaire
a travaillé là-dessus et c'est
absolument passionnant parce qu'il a
travaillé sur les journaux sur les
lettres et il se rend compte que tous
ces députés qui sont loin de chez eux
qui qui écrivent à leur épouse alors à
leurs enfants il y en a pas deux qui a
vécu la même chose ils ont fait la même
chose au même moment c'est ce que David
montre c'est une volonté nationale et
certains ont eu peur d'autres n'ont pas
compris certains pensaient qu'il faisait
ça pour le roi d'autres s'inquiète parce
que il voit bien que quelque chose ne va
pas plaire au roi et qui sont quand même
toujours révolutionnaire donc c'est pas
une journée qui rend tout le monde
révolution voilà et alors je voulais
qu'on parle aussi de ces dates qui n'ont
pas fait dates ces dates qui sont
tombées dans l'oubli et qui servent à
nous battre contre cette oubli et là
vous allez voir les images c'est le rôle
du détective que l'historien représente
alors que Sharon est dans les mémoires
le 17 octobre 1961 alors que c'est la
fin de la guerre d'Algérie et bien au
massacre les Algériens à Paris ou les
Francos algériens comment témoigne ces
images et pourquoi cette date-là n'est
pas restée là alors c'est ce sont des
images dramatiques du 17 octobre 1961 ou
un coup un
couvre-feu a été imposé à ce qu'on
appelait à ce moment-là les musulmans
d'Algérie et qui en fait ne sont pas
tout à fait des citoyens français comme
les autres puisque on leur interdit de
se de rassembler et de manifester ça se
termine par un massacre un massacre
colonial au cœur de la ville de Paris
mais précisément parce que on est en
République on saura jamais combien il y
a eu de morts beaucoup plusieurs
dizaines plusieurs centaines mais en
République on ne peut pas totalement
faire disparaître des des cadavres et
donc même si d'une certaine manière
alors là on peut dire ça a été un
mensonge d'État mais vous me dites
détective si vous lisez des polars vous
savez très bien que et bien le criminel
finit toujours par revenir sur les lieux
du crime pour effacer ces traces et
lorsqu'on essaye de montrer c'est
Emmanuel Blanchard qui le montre c'est
que lorsqu'on tente d'effacer des traces
on en laisse toujours d'autres pas
simplement celle qu'on a oublié
d'effacer mais celle qu'on laisse par le
seul fait d'avoir voulu les effacer et
là il y a une inversion de mémoire qui
est intéressante vous dites on parle
plus de Sharon oui quand j'étais
étudiant le massacre de Sharon
effectivement c'était des communistes
qui avaient été qui avait été donc
persécuté par la police avait une
empreinte mémorielle plus forte mais on
est en train justement de d'inverser la
mémoire ce qui fait que on pourrait dire
d'un événement que c'est ce qui finit
par advenir de ce qui est devenu
c'est-à-dire que c'est la mémoire qui
crée les reliefs de l'oubli et de la
remémoration alors vous dites aussi que
vous ne savez qu'une chose en tant
qu'historien c'est que l'histoire est
imprévisible et que elle ne se répète
pas ou très très rarement comment vous
vivez cette guerre en Ukraine Patrick
Boucheron avec ses paysages qui font
penser quand même à 14-18 c'est tranché
dans la neige ces mots de crimes de
guerre qui reviennent de génocide aussi
de viol d'atrocités de massacres de
bombardements les historiens vont
travailler on en est pas là encore parce
que c'est la guerre comment vous vivez
ça vous ça revient dites-vous et c'est
très exactement cette impression de
d'effraction que le réel produit dans
nos consciences c'est-à-dire que là le
24 février
2022 restera sans doute une date parce
que on s'est rendu compte que ce qui
paraissait assez loin nous nous affecter
directement et puis on s'est aussi
demandé pourquoi on avait oublié
pourquoi ont depuis 2014 depuis
l'invasion de la Crimée ça nous
paraissait finalement on avait oublié
que c'était l'Europe et puis vous vous
souvenez de ce qu'on a dit on a dit la
guerre revient dans au cœur de hauteur
de l'Europe alors que elle s'en était
absentée depuis 1945 et à ce moment-là
on aurait dû se souvenir que c'était des
30 ans de la de du siège de Sarajevo
donc ça veut dire que chaque moment de
REM
ce solde exactement comme le 17 octobre
par un oubli et et c'est quelque chose
que je trouve
très troublant parce que encore une fois
là là on n'est pas à l'école là on n'est
pas dans un livre on est dans nos vies
et nos vies c'est pas simplement nos
intimités on voit on a bien été payé
pendant le covid pour comprendre que
l'intérieur et l'extérieur l'intime et
le Global tout ça ça peut être traversé
l'histoire ça nous traverse merci
beaucoup c'est moi j'aurais pu vous
écouter encore longtemps Patrick
Boucheron quand l'histoire fait date 10
manières de créer l'événement c'est au
seuil Arte édition parce que ce livre
est inspiré de cette série géniale que
qui sera qui est toujours en ligne sur
YouTube et sur le site d'Arte quand
l'histoire fait date et il y aura une
suite m'avait vous dit je vous propose
de rester avec moi parce que c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos affranchis pour
leur partie pris ce soir ils sont deux
d'abord le philosophe Pierre-Henri
tavoyé ou va nous parler d'un livre qui
a connu un succès absolument phénoménale
en Italie un livre sur Mussolini et puis
Garou Marco pommier nous dira pourquoi
les élus donne de la voix face au ravage
du loup dans nos montagnes nos
affranchis les voici bonsoir à tous les
deux et merci d'être avec nous
Pierre-Henri tavoyau va commencer par
vous vous souhaitiez revenir sur le
succès d'un livre un livre écrit par un
écrivain italien Antonio curati sur
Mussolini sur c'est une saga c'est une
suite et le titre c'est M l'enfant du
siècle voilà il y en a il y a trois
volumes le dernier vient de paraître en
italien et le deuxième vient d'être
primé c'est un livre assez fascinant
parce que il nous place dans la
situation de les yeux de Mussolini
c'est-à-dire la montée on se met de son
point de vue et on arrive et on comprend
la puissance séductrice du fascisme
c'est c'est assez fascinant à tel point
d'ailleurs que quand on lit le livre on
a parfois on se surprend en soi-même à
avoir envie que le fascisme gagne et
donc c'est extrêmement intéressant comme
comme perspective parce qu'effectivement
c'est la montée en direct avec
évidemment après on retombe sur terre
assez vite et on voit effectivement les
dégâts absolument abominables c'est un
livre aussi passionnant parce que
a fait aussi une analyse très précise du
rapport entre populisme et fascisme et
dans un article récent du monde disait
que le même que ce qu'elle a été avaient
fait de Mussolini l'inventeur du
populisme le titre est toujours un peu
trompeur on connaît les médias mais
parce que très très voilà n'historien
aussi de très grandes règles il faut se
méfier des comparaisons hâtives et une
comparaison entre octobre 1922 c'est la
Marche sur Rome et octobre
2022 c'est la victoire de Jean-Jacques
miloni il faut pas établir de
comparaison trop hâtivement mais il dit
il y a une matrice il y a une matrice
Mussolini inaugure quelque chose qui est
tout à fait inédit et je vais lire les
trois idées qui qui la portent et qui
sont assez qui sont des citations de
Mussolini d'abord cette phrase je suis
le peuple le peuple c'est moi un phrase
qui incarne le populisme le premier
leader populiste c'est-à-dire la
préférence dans un système démocratique
ou qu'il est un peu de l'Incarnation à
la logique représentative il s'agit
d'incarner le peuple et non pas le le
représenter première différence deuxième
différence une détestation profonde de
la politique
de sale cette phrase nous ne sommes pas
la politique nous sommes l'antipolitique
nous ne sommes pas un parti nous sommes
l'antipartiment on retrouve la logique
de l'anti-système qu'on retrouve
effectivement aussi dans les populistes
enfin l'idée que le chef ne doit pas
guider mais suivre la masse un peu comme
un comme un comme un berger qui suit
alors on parle des loups mais un berger
qui suit qui suit le troupeau je suis
dit Mussolini l'homme de l'après je suis
comme les bêtes je flirt le temps qui
vient ce sont trois postulants animés
par un moteur profond face à la peur que
le monde contemporain suscite chez
l'individualisé c'est la peur et seule
la haine est plus fort que la peur voilà
alors on peut discuter quand même ces
tests parce que incontestablement c'est
puissant comme comme regard
va juger mais il y a malgré tout je
crois trois différences très importantes
entre ce populisme originaire et le
populisme contemporain d'abord le
fascisme il faut le rappeler et
viscéralement anti-démocratique l'idée
même de démocratie il la déteste alors
que le populisme contemporain est hyper
démocratique le peuple contemporain veut
toujours plus de peuples et toujours
plus de pouvoir
deuxième différence très importante le
fascisme est hyper élitiste
ilypéraélitisme le populisme
contemporain est ultra égalitaire c'est
une différence majeure parce que le
fascisme fait l'éloge des hiérarchies
naturelles il détestent les petits les
faibles les médiocres non on est enfin
troisième idéologie une idéologie
structure et le fascisme est une
idéologie structurée
musolini est un intellectuel un grand
intellectuel bien des heures on peut
évidemment contester mais un grand
intellectuel mais aujourd'hui le
populisme c'est une idéologie molle
extrêmement sans contenu sans
philosophie de l'histoire sans avenir
radieux et là c'est une troisième
différence essentielle merci merci
Pierre-Henri tavoyau quelques mots pour
réagir très rapidement que j'ai tant de
nouvelles
c'est effectivement les romans mais les
romans anciens anciens le savaient déjà
et que l'histoire soit un art du point
de vue vous l'avez très bien dit l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est pas de traiter des
autres de fasciste c'est de reconnaître
la tentation fasciste c'est-à-dire d'une
certaine manière cette cette pente vers
le gouvernement autoritaire qui semble
voilà être sinon notre destin du moins
un de nos possibles allez on va passer
au loup il lui reste quand même un petit
peu de temps mais un peu moins que
d'habitude Marco pour le loup certains
députés contre les loups s'insurgent et
bien contre ceux qui ont remis le loup
dans les montagnes c'est ça parce que
les baveurs font les frais Myriam alors
si vous me parlez de ce sujet tout de
suite je convoque Pierre Morel à
l'huissier c'est un peu le monsieur loup
de l'Assemblée très engagé sur la
question depuis plusieurs années au
point d'interpeller le gouvernement dans
l'hémicycle même quand c'est pas le
sujet du jour c'était le cas début
décembre on parlait retraite agricole et
lui il nous parle du
monsieur le ministre je profite de
d'être d'avoir la parole pour vous
demander de bien vouloir intervenir
auprès de vos collègues fait nous et le
ministre de l'écologie sur la prédation
du loup je ne comprends pas monsieur le
ministre que la France est votée contre
la révision de la Convention de Berne il
y a quelques jours c'est inacceptable et
il faut que ça soit dit voilà il fait
donc référence à la Convention de Berne
en fait à Strasbourg il y a deux
semaines la Suisse proposée de faire
passer le loup de la liste des espèces
strictement protégées à celle des
espèces protégées la France s'est
opposée à cet amendement alors c'est
vrai que Myriam que nous apparaît on n'a
pas vu beaucoup de loups un rodé dans
les environs de l'Assemblée pourtant le
canidé et l'argent chaque année un peu
plus son territoire officiellement il y
aurait près d'un millier de loups en
France écoutez à nouveau Pierre Morel à
lui si en ce moment il est avec notre
conso Maïté Frémont pour traquer le loup
en Lozère le loup qui fait des ravages
dans les élevages là-bas il faut
comprendre que ça coûte économique c'est
un coup de social ça coûte psychologique
pour de jeunes agriculteurs ils sont et
ils se demandent aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on veut notre disparition ou est-ce
qu'on on est prêt à nous accompagner
dans ces difficultés liées à la présence
d'un loup qui il y a design une dizaine
d'années concernés 5 idées départements
et aujourd'hui on dénombre 55
départements impactés par le loup voilà
Pierre Morel à l'huissier qui dénonce un
préjudice psychologique entraînant des
suicides chez les éleveurs et plus
largement une destruction de notre
modèle d'élevage trop c'est trop affirme
certains parlementaires ils sont 24 à
taper du point sur la table 13 députés
11 sénateurs à l'Assemblée une
proposition de loi de Pierre Morel à
huissier encore lui a été déposé pour
renforcer les pouvoirs des préfets pour
contrôler pour réguler ses espèces des
parlementaires qui envisagent aussi des
procédures judiciaires contre le
gouvernement allez jusqu'au pénal contre
le loup exactement c'est parlementaires
en fait il considèrent que l'État aband
ces éleveurs et donc ils entendent
déposer une centaine de plaintes auprès
de la Cour de Justice de la République
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
et non-assistance à personne en danger
marcéno et Christophe Béchu les
ministres de l'Agriculture et de
l'écologie sont dans le viseur histoire
à suivre merci beaucoup merci les
affranchis et merci Patrick Boucheron
d'être passé par la chaîne parlementaire
quand l'histoire fait date c'est au
seuil c'est la fin de cette émission
demain Clément Méric au manette pour la
dernière de l'année 2022 je vous
retrouve le 10 janvier dans un nouveau
studio vous verrez il est absolument
magnifique grand merci à tous ceux qui
m'accompagnent malheureusement je n'ai
pas le temps de tous les citer toute
l'équipe sévère évidemment en premier
lieu la rédaction la production la régie
à très vite passée de très belles fêtes
prenez soin des vôtres et profitez bien
belle soirée
[Musique]